bonsoir à tous bienvenue au parlement
européen à bruxelles europe hebdo cette
semaine revient sur la crise des
migrants
c'est l'impasse l'union européenne se
ferment direction y dominent ils 2 min
c'est un petit village frontalier entre
la grèce et la macédoine
ce village anonyme et tranquille est
devenu depuis quelques mois dans un
premier temps le centre de transit des
migrants de la route des balkans est
aujourd'hui un immense camp informel
composé de tentes depuis l'accord entre
l'europe et la turquie
les migrants ne peuvent plus passer elle
se retrouve coincé dans un entre deux
entre la grèce et la macédoine
et puis on se posera la question après
la syrie la turquie la libye sera t-elle
le prochain théâtre de la crise des
migrants 6 à 7000 personnes franchissent
la méditerranée en ce moment à
destination de l'italie
tous les mois des centaines de milliers
seraient sur place en libye en attendant
de faire de même et pour les migrants
arrivés en france cette fois un constat
les migrants qui sont en france eh bien
ils ne veulent pas rester en france ils
veulent souvent rejoindre la grande
bretagne
là bas on trouve du travail plus
facilement et il y à la solidarité des
familles et des communautés leurs
reportages à londres avec des migrants
seconde partie d'émission nos invités ce
soir sylvie guillaume eurodéputée
socialiste jean-marie cavada eurodéputés
du groupe libéral et démocrate
-enfin louis aliot député européen et
vice-président du front national avant
de commencé de débattre avec eux je vous
propose d'aller à idaux mendy assez ce
camp en grèce à la frontière avec la
macédoine
les réfugiés sont pris en sandwich
impossible de rentrer à l'intérieur de
la grèce comme des milliers d'autres
réfugiés bloqués jihan une réfugiée
syrienne commence à s'habituer la
routine du camp elle espère que son
périple arrivera bientôt à sa fin à leur
portage de joey sinclair et armand
soldats
elle est malade est enceinte depuis deux
mois
jihan vide depuis des semaines dans une
tente à la frontière gréco macédonienne
pour avoir risqué la vie de ses deux
enfants
d'abord pour quitter la série est
ensuite traversé la mer egée depuis la
turquie
jn espérait bien plus maintenant qu'à la
maison on ne s'attendait pas à vivre ici
comme ça j'aurais préféré qu'on reste en
syrie pour qu'on n'ait pas à vivre une
vie pareille
nous pleurons jour et nuit nous pleurons
même lorsque mangeons c'est une honte
qu'on est à vivre comme ça entendez nous
laisser nous traverser comme elle ils
sont plus de 11 mille migrants et
réfugiés à être bloquée à idaux mendy au
nord de la grèce
beaucoup refusent de bouger dans
l'espoir que la frontière s'ouvre enfin
et les rumeurs n'aide pas il y a
quelques jours les familles avaient
commencé à rassembler leurs affaires
après avoir entendu que la frontière à
l'est où rires vous salert la
manifestation qui s'en est suivie est
resté largement pacifiques mais le
désespoir est bien réelle rim voit
j'ai 72 ans ma femme est morte et je
suis un vieil homme
je n'ai rien en syrie pas de maison pas
d'argent pas de boulot a plus aucune
raison de vivre
le seul espoir c'est l'europe ces
derniers jours environ 1500 personnes
ont embarqué à bord de bus en direction
d'autres camps selon les autorités
grecques qui leur ont promis de
meilleures conditions
mais beaucoup préfèrent rester proche de
la frontière par crainte que le monde
les oublie s'il se disperse pour les
grecs qui souffre déjà d'une politique
d'austérité accablante la crise des
migrants n'a rien arrangé
les agriculteurs locaux bien que
sensible à la souffrance des réfugiés se
retrouve dans une situation très
difficile
leurs chants ont été piétinées et leurs
récoltes détruites
c'est un grand problème un grand
problème et si ça continue encore
longtemps que dieu nous aide
ils vont devoir rester ici et nous
allons devoir partir à la frontière
gréco macédonienne personne ne sait de
quoi demain sera fait mais en attendant
les jours passent et la situation
autrefois exceptionnel est devenu
routine
les habitants du camp ont désormais leur
propre stand et d'autres s'improvise
barbier les frontières ont beau être
fermés les réfugiés didot mais n'y sont
encore loin d'être arrivé
aulas reportage de jouer sinclair et
armand soldats nous ont joints sur ce
plateau sylvie guillaume bonsoir vous
êtes eurodéputé socialiste élu de la
circonscription rhône-alpes paca corse à
vous êtes vice présidente du parlement
européen vous êtes rendu en turquie il
ya un mois et demi un pour voir de vos
propres yeux la situation sur place ces
réfugiés qui viennent de syrie et d'irak
vous allez nous en parler à vos côtés
jean-marie cavada bonsoir vous êtes
eurodéputés du groupe des libéraux et
démocrates élus depuis 2004 élu dans la
circonscription ile de france vous êtes
aussi président de génération citoyens
et du mouvement européen-france merci
d'être venu enfin louis aliot vous êtes
député européen ou député français au
parlement européen c'est comme ça que
vous présentez en tout cas du groupe
europe des nations et des libertés lui
de la circonscription sud-ouest
conseiller municipal de perpignan
vous êtes aussi bien sûr vice-président
du front national on vient de voir le
reportage la macédoine renvoie ces
migrants vers la grèce qui elle même
n'en veut pas du coup personne ne s'en
occupe ya un blocage
sylvie guillaume vous avez raison de
dire que personne ne s'en occupe de
manière raisonnée est répartie l'union
européenne par le biais de fonds
européens avec les os et les
associations internationales présentes
sur place s'occupe comme elles le
peuvent de la situation de ces personnes
est le vrai problème c'est que d'une
part il ya un conflit qui perdure qui
serez j-10 fine et qui doit être traité
et d'autre part il y a une forme
d'isolement d'hypocrisie et de l'absence
de solidarité dans la manière de traiter
ensemble cette question qui est une
question grave qui à mon avis est
explosif pour la question les lignes
européennes alors l'europe elle n'a pas
pu gérer tout seul cette affaire elle
son permis à la turquie un accord a été
signé avec ankara ankara qui s'engage à
reprendre les migrants est ce qu'on peut
faire à un petit bilan de cet accord
aujourd'hui où c'est trop tôt jean marie
cavada
d'abord je voudrais que tout le monde
comprenne bien qu'il s'agit d'un dame
mondiale planétaire et non pas d'une
question de culpabilité de l'europe ou
de refus de jouer son rôle de certaines
des nations c'est un problème planétaire
d'abord je rappelle que les états unis
sont intervenus militairement dans cette
région et c'est la raison pour laquelle
je pense qu'on aurait dû opérer très
différemment
on aurait dû se traiter cette question
comme ce fut le cas lors des boat people
en 76 un problème ça détermine en a on
n'a pas anticipé ça fait quatre ans que
je vous explique que vous voulez bien on
aurait dû traiter ça comme on l'a fait
pour les boat people du vietnam et du
cambodge c'est à dire la communauté
internationale dans son ensemble réparé
parce que ce sont des gens dans un très
mauvais état et ensuite on répartit or
là on a tout mis ça sur le dos de
l'europe à l'exception de 25000 que le
canada très généreusement d'ailleurs et
qui est ainsi qu il détient un système
migratoire qui marchent à accepter chez
lui ça c'est une première chose
deuxièmement on a sous traité
faute d'avoir accepté la proposition ukr
du mois de mai dernier qui était une
bonne proposition à mes yeux parce
qu'elle tenait compte de différents
paramètres pour qu'il n'y ait pas je
dirais une sorte de de superposition
massive de réfugiés dans des pays qui
était petit ou qu'ils avaient du chômage
etc
on n'a pas voulu accepter cette
proposition ça c'est l'égoïsme des états
ça suffit de dire que c'est l'europe et
l'europe c'est le secrétariat général de
ce que les états ne veulent pas faire ne
veulent pas décidé ont peur de dessiner
ou bien se mettre je dirais dans le dans
le sillage de la peur qui est exploité
par foi et la raison pour laquelle on a
signé cet accord avec la turquie
et bien c'est une façon de sous traiter
notre propre impuissance cet accord pour
l'instant fonctionne très très
moyennement il ailleurs il est en train
de se bloquer parce que la turquie on
pouvait s'y attendre revendique haut et
fort que les visas soient supprimées
pour ses ressortissants ainsi que nous
l'avons accepté d'ailleurs louis aliot
la souffrance de ces réfugiés syriens on
a vu dans le reportage ça vous touche
oui évidemment il en touche mais
j'allais dire il lui fallut prendre le
problème à la source et nous sommes
malheureusement en tant que gouvernement
même pas de l'union européenne
moi j'ai problème du gouvernement de
france est en partie responsable de ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui et qui a il
faut le dire
déséquilibré non seulement cette région
mais aujourd'hui en train de
déséquilibrer l'offre la sphère de libye
les mauvais choix ainsi rang ont été ou
sont au coeur de la déstabilisation de
l'ensemble et finalement on est toujours
dans réparer les conséquences de l'amour
vez politique que nous avons menée eh
bien il fallait y penser avant
maintenant il ya l'urgence sociale
humanitaire
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
d'associations humanitaires qui font
beaucoup je pense qu'on aurait dû faire
des corridors humanitaires à la hausse
sur les côtes notamment de la libye et
en syrie protéger évidemment pour
maintenir ces populations mais là
évidemment on a affaire à un flot de
population miséreuse qui fuient la
guerre et il faut d'urgence choisir les
bons alliés
on s'est aperçu un peu tard qu'en syrie
il fallait négocier avec les russes
l'accord avec la turquie c'est plus
délicat parce que la turquie fait du
chantage aujourd'hui c'est clair elle
dit moi je vous bloque ou en tout cas je
gère les migrants si on discute sur les
visas et même je crois sur la relance
des négociations d'adhésion de la
turquie en europe
mais encore une fois je pense qu'il faut
aussi se projeter sur nous mêmes et sur
la politique que l'on mène est encore
une chose sur les migrants parce que
personne ne le dit moi j'ai fait
campagne dans le sud ouest j'ai
rencontré par exemple les thoniers les
marines de méditerranée les thoniers de
méditerranée
ça fait pratiquement cinq ou six ans qui
sont témoins de ces boat people de libye
de syrie qu'ils alertent l'opinion c'est
important qu'ils savent qu'ils
fabriquent les bateaux qui donne des
moteurs à ces bateaux quels sont les
passeurs 4000 à 5000 $ par migrants sur
ces bateaux à tout risque et pourtant
personne ne s'en occupe
moi ça me pose quand même et guillaume
vous étiez en turquie il ya un mois et
demi
comment ça se fait que commence à spa
début mars mais comment ça se passe sur
place
écoutez vous nous faire un petit bilan
canaux d ce que j'ai dit ce que j'ai vu
effectivement je peux vous faire un
bilan mais dans un seul ensemble
effectivement beaucoup plus larges ont
quand même regarder la réalité en face
au niveau mondial il y a environ 60
millions de personnes qui se déplacent
chaque année de 10 déplacer parce que
leur situation évidemment sont
différentes et les motifs de leurs
déplacements sont différents mais
déplacer ça veut bien dire forcer à se
déplacer et ses 60 millions de personnes
elle ne déferle pas tout sur l'union
européenne évidemment la plupart d'entre
elles ont des déplacements dans ce qu'on
appelle le loco régionale trouvent des
refuges trouve un moyen d'être protégés
dans un espace
régional en turquie environ environ 2
millions 700 mille syriens sont arrivés
hébergé pour une petite partie d'entre
eux 11% environ dans des camps qui sont
des camps de containers qui sont plutôt
bien organisée très maîtrisée avec des
espaces de scolarisation des espaces de
marché de supermarchés les espaces de
culte un hôpital donc cette partie là je
dirais soit en containers mais aussi en
quand il ya une grosse partie de ses
différents espaces d'hébergement qui
sont en sous tente également globalement
sont maîtrisés mais la réalité c'est que
quelle près de 90% des syriens qui sont
arrivés en turquie ne sont pas dans les
camps ils sont enregistrés mais ils ne
sont pas dans l'exposition en ville avec
dans des espaces qui sont infra
humanitaire ans dans le par exemple à
gaziantep le plus de trois cent mille
personnes sont dans des conditions tout
à fait inacceptables il faut aussi
pardonnez moi juste encore un mot
imaginez que la zone complète comprend
aussi la jordanie et le liban qu'on ne
doit pas oublier dans tout cela qu'ils
sont soumis ces deux pays à une très
grande pression également avec la
présence d'énormément de syriens
globalement si nous projetions le nombre
de personnes syrienne dans ces trois
pays
il y aurait 10 7 millions de personnes
en france qui serait installé
donc ça a un impact nécessairement sur
les pays qui accueillent ces personnes
il y à la grèce donc la turquie il y
avait pas seulement il ya un an 800
migrants sont morts noyés au large des
côtes libyennes à la libye dont vous
faisiez référence il ya quelques jours
près de 500 personnes
il y aurait encore péril selon le haut
commissariat aux réfugiés crise
migratoire est ce que c'est pas un échec
moral
on sauver l'euro mais on sauve pas des
vies grand c'est parce que en ce moment
des d'autres routes se constitue à
partir du moment où il y a une forme
d'impasse et difficultés je reprends ce
que dit monsieur galvada l'instance sur
les les accords avec la thur entre
l'union européenne et la turquie est
quelque chose qui fonctionne mal il n'a
pas de base légale correct et de façon
défi car matière d'efficacité
ils ne résistent pas à l'épreuve et la
route de balkans est également fermée
donc ces gens qui n'ont pas d'espoir qui
pour certains d'entre eux depuis quatre
ans sont dans les camps dont on parlait
tout à l'heure ils ne voient pas le bout
de ce conflit ils ne voient pas le bout
et nous pas de futur pour remettre
dedans qu'il reconstitue une autre route
aidé en cela il faut en dire un mot
sérieux très sérieux par des passeurs
j'ai effectivement depuis de nombreuses
années font du business sur la pauvreté
et maintenant on recrée ce qu'on appelle
la route via la libye et qui va repasser
donc par l'italie et remonter donc vers
l'italie via matin
la libye c'est le prochain théâtre de
file sur la crise des migrants jean
marie cavada
c'est pas le prochain c'est déjà et déjà
oui je voudrais dire un mot sur les
valeurs auxquelles il est fait allusion
il faut faire très attention à ces
choses là
la politique c'est des combats les
décisions parfois on les comprend pas
bien mais il en 1992 match triste déjà
disait que la question de l'immigration
irrégulière est une question d'intérêt
commun
c'est quand on fait de cette question
d'intérêt sommation et très intéressante
en 92 dans des responsabilités
différentes j'allais très souvent en
espagne notamment lorsqu'il s'est agi de
l'exposition universelle
et quand on allait à séville la
télévision locale pas la télévision
nationale qui n'en voulait pas montrer
les cadavres de gens qui avaient essayé
de traverser dans des petites
embarcations et à la nage la distance
qui savent qui sépare tanger du détroit
enfin le détroit de gibraltar
c'est une très vieille question et
l'europe à devoir moral très clair je ne
dis pas comme avait dit rocard en son
temps que l'europe doivent absorber tous
les malheurs du monde c'est impossible
et ce en septembre il avait ajouté elle
doit y prendre sa part c'est pourquoi je
répète que c'est un problème mondial qui
doit être traité notamment avec les
américains notamment avec des asiatiques
ceux qui ont une voix à l'onu de façon à
ce que nous puissions faire face
humainement c'était assez à faire
l'europe elle s'est construite sur un
seul but plus jamais ça plus jamais quoi
plus jamais la destruction des européens
par
même la discussion des valeurs avec
lesquelles nous vivons dont nous avons
besoin pour vivre ensemble par nous
mêmes eh bien nous avons un devoir de
solidarité nous qui avons jeté des
dizaines de millions d'européens sur les
routes au 20e siècle
il faut qu'on en prenne sa part
intelligemment comme on le fait par
exemple au canada
c'est à dire obligation de trouver
l'argent pour apprendre la langue aux
immigrés que l'on accepte
deuxièmement leur trouver un toit
troisièmement leur trouver un travail
ceci devrait faire l'objet d'un débat
national
ça fait 30 ans que les gouvernements
sont trop courts pour s'aventurer dans
cette affaire et pourtant il n'y aura
pas de légitimité à cette action si nous
ne passons pas par là je voulais vous
faire réagir à cette information qui va
pas arranger le sort des migrants des
révélations du washington post un
reprise par le journal le monde
ah si on peut voir le bon titre là un
algérien et un pakistanais interpellé en
autriche qui passe aux aveux
il devait participer aux attentats de
paris le 13 novembre ils ont pris la
route dans les pas des migrants à des
lada dit à gauche sur la photo 29 ans
s'est envolée d'alger le 15 février 2015
pour istanbul puis rejoindra cas en
syrie où il est recruté avec son
collègue pakistanais à droite sur la
photo et deux autres irakiens
il part de jaca en syrie jusqu'en
turquie inde et passeur turc les emmène
vers la grèce par bateau avec 50
migrants ils arrivent sur l'île de
l'eros par chance ils sont arrêtés en
grèce pour faux passeport ils n'iront
pas à paris commettre les attentats mais
les deux autres irakiens si elles sont
passés entre les gouttes elles se feront
sauter au stade de france
donc sur la photo non avec cette affaire
est ce qu'on va pas dire les migrants
c'est des terroristes en puissance
c'est absolument épouvantable que ce que
la question sous-entend les terroristes
s'il y en a deux qui sont passés il y en
a sans doute plus d'ailleurs des
apprentis ou des gens qui veulent et ça
c'est le lot de tous les grands
déplacements de masses non contrôlée ils
ont utilisé la filière et d'ailleurs et
il ya une réponse très claire à faire à
votre question c'est que si les
gouvernements européens à partir de 2004
moi je me souviens je préside a ici la
commission des libertés civiles qui a
dans son portefeuille
la question migratoire les gouvernements
refusé de payer l'argent pour contrôler
les frontières extérieures de l'europe
où on aurait eu des points de passage
contrôlé et de cette manière on aurait
eu une idée de l'évaluation de ce qu'on
pouvait faire et est allé jusqu'au bout
de notre devoir encore une fois
participé jeudi
à la halle à la misère du monde donc je
ne veux pas aller plus loin sur les deux
qui se sont infiltrés là dedans il y en
a sans doute beaucoup plus d'ailleurs il
ya des milliers des centaines de
milliers de gens qui sont passés faut
pas rêver mais vous savez s'il ne venait
pas par là il n'est par ailleurs et
d'autre part je vous rappelle que les
principaux acteurs de ces drames
il était français ils étaient belles ils
vivaient ici lui aliot c'est une des
filières du passage des terroristes et
on a vu ce que ça pouvait donner
il fallait évidemment assurer un
meilleur contrôle mais ça pose ce n'est
pas une immigration économique
c'est une migration de guerre une petite
partie est une immigration économique
il faut donc comme je le disais tout à
l'heure quand même s'occuper d'eux d'où
proviennent ces ces immigrés parce que
pour la plupart d'entre eux quand vous
discutez avec eux ils n'y vont pas de
gaieté de coeur à faire le voyage qu'il
faut riz le font parce qu'ils y sont
obligés à moins qu'ils aient de
mauvaises intentions comme les
terroristes
que fait-on aujourd'hui pour rétablir
les équilibres dans cette région en
syrie
que fait-on aujourd'hui en libye parce
que vous parliez tout à l'heure de la
libye il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui le
terrain perdu en syrie par l'état
islamique est aujourd'hui reconquérir en
quelque sorte en libye d'une manière
assez tragique d'ailleurs et donc il
faut s'attendre dans les jours qui
arrivent dans les semaines qui arrivent
à une déstabilisation encore plus grande
de la libye et c'est là que nous
attendons des fortes des décisions
fortes qui ne sont pas simplement être à
la remorque de la politique américaine
je rappelle quand même que l' aventure
américaine en irak a coûté la vie à 170
mille civils pour le résultat que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui
donc peut-être que la france pourrait
avoir aussi sa voix son message sa
politique arabe et sortir de ce schéma
il faut bien le dire de l'otan et de la
politique américaine qui nous amène
beaucoup d'ennuis et peut davantage dans
la situation actuelle sur la
méditerranée qui devient un cercueil
il ya le rôle un peu ambigu de l'agencé
frontex une agence européenne qui
surveille 14 mille kilomètres de
frontières extérieure pour qu'on puisse
circuler librement à l'intérieur faut
contrôler
l'extérieur mais frontex surveille mais
ne veuille pas dans son mandat il n'ya
pas le sauvetage des genres le statut de
frontex a toujours été en discussion
depuis très très longtemps c'est une
agence qui a beaucoup grossi et qui
risque de grossir encore puisqu'on va
guînes b pour ni du parlement européen
et de la commission européenne frontex
est très régulièrement devant le
parlement européen devant la commission
des libertés civiles de la justice et
des affaires intérieures pour rendre
compte de ce qui est fait est par
ailleurs le parlement européen est
consulté et doit donner son avis sur le
mandat de fond texte sur la manière dont
tu y es dont l âge et donc il ya
plusieurs sujets c'est l agence qui a
beaucoup grossi et qui va grossir encore
plus puisque normalement est toute la
gestion garde-côtes gardes frontières va
lui être confiées au terme de la
discussion
mais le problème n'est pas vraiment là
je reviens sur ce que vous indiquiez
tout à l'heure où avec le bruit
rapidement mais en même temps c'est un
sujet bien sûr de sicile qu'on ne peut
pas traiter en dessous des niveaux
d'avant hier à pau à la fois la question
de traiter sur place des difficultés
rencontrées pour un motif ou pour un
autre économique dans certains états des
états de guerre qui génèrent une demande
de protection internationale s'est
effectivement gérer le passage et donc
avoir nécessairement si ce n'est les
corridors comme disait monsieur aliot
tout à l'heure mais au moins des voies
légales qui soit contrôlée qui luttent
contre les voies incontrôlée de passage
et il s'agit aussi de traiter la
question de l'intégration une fois que
les personnes sont arrivées sur leur
statut de réfugié quand c'est le cas sur
la statue de migrants économiques hans
et cas mais c'est un ensemble et c'est
pour ça que la proposition de la
commission il ya quelques mois de cela
qui était une proposition transversale
qui englobait toutes les politiques de
migration etc c'est de les traiter en
tuyaux d'orgue effectivement était une
proposition intéressante elle s'est
heurtée à l'égoïsme des étalons qui
n'ont pas voulu du tout de cette
solidarité et sur les migrants donc
qu'ils sont qui sont en france à constat
les migrants qui sont en france c'est
bien ils ne veulent pas rester en france
ils veulent souvent rejoindre la grande
bretagne
là bas ils disent les migrants disant
qu'ils trouvent du travail plus
facilement il y aller solidarité des
familles et des communautés le reportage
à londres de rim benameur
la jungle de calais des milliers de
migrants qui s'entassent des conditions
de vie précaires et un rêve
l'angleterre ici la vie n'est pas bonne
vous le voyez par vous même je ne suis
pas heureux je veux aller au royaume-uni
là bas c'est mieux l'angleterre accepte
n'importe quelle situation politique
n'importe quel dossier ce n'est pas
compliqué de trouver un boulot c'est
facile d'avoir rapidement une nouvelle
vie se fabriquer une nouvelle vie
trouver du travail
est ce plus facile de l'autre côté de la
manche rudy et syriens il est arrivé en
angleterre il ya trois ans après avoir
fui la guerre
les débuts sont difficiles mais il
obtient son statut de réfugié en
quelques mois et décroche rapidement un
travail de cuisine
j'ai travaillé deux ans dans le centre
de londres j'ai mis de l'argent de côté
et je suis venu ici j'ai ouvert mon
business avec mon ami brahim nous sommes
tous deux réfugiés de syrie nous avons
ouvert notre business ensemble nous
voulons travailler payer des impôts nous
avons ouvert notre affaire la vie est
enfin meilleur maintenant dès son
arrivée rudy a été aidé par des amis
syriens
en angleterre les nouveaux arrivants
peuvent compter sur la solidarité sans
faille des familles et des communautés
sisvel est volée va d'abord c'est très
précieux d'avoir de l'aide de personnes
arrivées avant vous elle vous guide vous
informe sur vos droits vous aide
comment trouver un travail ou des cours
d'anglais nous avons de nombreux groupes
sur les réseaux sociaux des groupes
facebook par exemple des gens postent
des annonces quand ils ont un travail à
proposer ils demandent si quelqu'un est
intéressé et les gens les contacter
directement des communautés bien
organisés et un marché du travail plus
favorable 2 % de croissance en 2015 et
un taux de chômage à 5,6 pour cent soit
deux fois moins qu'en france et ici le
travail au noir est beaucoup plus
répandu il est assez facile de trouver
du travail au noir ici nous avons un
marché dérégulé ce sont des choix
politiques
donc on peut travailler facilement il
n'y a pas de carte d'identité pas de
contrôles réguliers
donc c'est vrai que beaucoup vivent de
façon illégale mais ils travaillent et
vivent ici comme des gens normaux marché
du travail plus souple travail au noir
la réputation des britanniques a donc
dépassé les frontières
le pays accueille aujourd'hui plus d'un
million de personnes dans l'illégalité
mais le parti conservateur au pouvoir
est bien décidé à changer cette image de
paradis économique une loi discutée au
parlement vise à renforcer les contrôles
et les expulsions
la grande bretagne est un pays qui
attire beaucoup
nous avons la croissance peu de chômage
c'est un endroit sûr et prospère
c'est pourquoi les gens veulent venir
légalement et illégalement
nous disons vous était bienvenu si vous
venez légalement sinon notre police aux
frontières et notre ministère de
l'intérieur vous traquerons renforcer
également la lutte contre le travail
illégal avec notamment de la prison pour
les employeurs et une saisie sur salaire
pour les travailleurs comme en france
l'accueil est souvent précaire
environ 200 euros par mois et un
logement sommaire et la nouvelle loi a
drastiquement réduit les aides car on a
créé notre gouvernement a délibérément
choisi de créer un environnement hostile
et je pense que ce n'est pas la solution
par exemple cette loi qui retire toute
aide à des familles qui ont été rejetées
dans leur demande d'asile
ça crée des situations dramatiques ce
n'est pas la réponse d'un pays civilisé
avec ces nouvelles mesures
l'angleterre pourrait perdre un jour son
image d'eldorado des migrants mais pour
l'instant sa force d'attraction reste
intacte
voilà reportage de rym ben ameur une
réaction ce reportage lui à lui aliot là
c'est un peu langres où la france non
merci ça vous arrange plutôt non c'est
pas ça c'est pas le même modèle les
états unis le modèle anglo saxon n'est
pas le modèle d'intégration du modèle
français qui est plutôt basée sur la
simulation
la france a connu des vagues
d'immigration en fait je veux dire les
espagnols et portugais les polonais les
italiens se sont fondus dans la masse au
point qu'aujourd'hui plus personne ne
fait la différence de rien ça même été
vrai à une époque avec les algériens et
du tunisien
mais à partir du moment où la pression
se fait trop importante et c'est là où
je suis pas d'accord avec madame ce
n'est pas de l'égoïsme national
c'est une réalité il ya 9 millions de
pauvres en france
vous le savez vous êtes une élue locale
où vous connaissez les problèmes n'y a
pas de logement les gens n'ont pas de
travail
comment voulez vous qu'ils acceptent que
des gens venus de nulle part pour eux
bénéficient de faveur sociale alors que
eux mêmes n'en bénéficient pas je pense
que m'ont donné ce n'est pas de
l'égoïsme c'est de la priorité aux
nationaux à la citoyenneté
parce que je pense qu'on ne peut pas
accueillir toute la misère du monde
n'est pas de l'égoïsme ne se dégage non
mais je pense que monsieur aliot confond
de chauffe quand je parle d' égoïsme des
états je parle du système général par
lequel il était possible de traiter
cette crise et vous avez vous même
indiqué qu'il fallait traiter cette
crise dans ses différentes dimensions
monsieur cavada fort justement tout à
l'heure insisté sur le fait qu' il y
avait des critères qui permettait de
répartir cette population temporairement
pour leur octroyer cette protection
internationale tant que chez eux ils
menacent d'être tué donc la wii
l'égoïsme national de tous les états
membres de l'union
c'est effectivement exprimé devant
recevoir france qu'il en soit je croyais
en campagne
oui alors que quelques centaines le
chiffre précisé l'élu 30000 oui mais
dans le petit nombre des personnes
qu'ils ont qui ont effectivement été
relocalisés la france prend la plus
grosse part de petits nombres de règles
de relocaliser donc voilà vont regarder
les choses en face c'est le mot de la
fin
mike cavanagh on voit cette voie simple
pour moi il ya deux choses
on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
ne pas regarder qu'il faut d'abord
aujourd'hui nouer des alliances fortes
pour installer la paix dans cette région
donc je pense qu'il faut maintenant
discuter avec la russie pour avoir le
seul et même adversaire la politique
étrangère alors d'abord deuxièmement
nous devons prendre notre part notre
part celles qu'on peut
celle où on peut traiter humainement les
gens de ceux qui sont qui fuient la
guerre quand on voit des réfugiés
syriens
parions moi j'en vois deux ou trois
familles qu'est ce qu'ils disent des
cures à la pêche chez moi c'est pas mon
pays et je peux pas rester ici
merci la france mais je voudrais rentrer
chez moi il faut prendre ces deux
notions pour établir une politique qui
soit juste
je crois que sur ce point vous serez
tous les trois d'accord merci à vous
trois d'avoir accepté notre invitation
s'est pas dérobé hebdo merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis la semaine prochaine
vous retrouvez nos ramadi à cette même
place
d'ici là bonne suite des programmes sur
les chaînes parlementaires bail